le stade rodez parties trouvent le moyen
le plus difficile de jouer au monté en
haut mais c'est très gratifiant
gratifiant parce que bébé 3,16 un mètre
cinquante de bâti tout en force en
puissance et en souplesse a un talent
d'exception
allez ça fait 3 go française sans fin à
des semaines de dire vraiment une
journée 100 % ou d'un homme est un gros
mouvement des troupes russes explosive à
sa première présence au championnat
canadien en mai dernier elle a remporté
le titre de vitesse c'est à dire monter
le plus rapidement possible un mur de 15
m c'est vraiment un bon moment
après dix pages puis hockey au monde le
canada on n'est pas très bon en justice
fake c'est le fun fun fun mais je tends
quand vous travaillez à les jeunes mais
réaliste babet à raison du travail il y
en a encore beaucoup parce que l'
escalade de murs demande de nombreuses
habiletés physiques
ces entraînements sont difficile
exigeant mais ce faux traitements un peu
la terre descendu en rouge c'est aussi
un sport où il ya énormément de
frustration les erreurs les chutes font
partie de l'apprentissage
tout ça me fait vraiment chier si borel
je le prends vraiment mal à chaque fois
fini ça me permet juste de travailler
mon caractère pi de compétition j'arrive
et je vais peut-être avoir une situation
frustrante mais j'ai déjà l'avoir vécu
fait que je peux le mieux gérer les
frustrations
ce genre sur wii babette doit apprendre
à gérer son intensité six émotions
elle a aussi besoin de se comparer aux
meilleurs c'est au canada en oeuvre on
peut autant de ressources que met-on en
europe parce qu'en europe ils vont tout
compétitionner entre eux alain lte et
parce que les coupes d'europe fait que
je pense seulement que c'est une vraie
paix entre qui répare fort c'est moi je
me suis quand même tout seul où je crée
pas avec marco mon coach et rendra à 30
seulement fait si ça reste restreignant
de comme pauvre le niveau en dehors
c'est mort
ben escalade babet va participer au
cours des prochains mois à quelques
rencontres internationales elle pourra
voir le chemin qui lui reste à parcourir
si elle veut atteindre son objectif
participer aux jeux olympiques marie
josée turcotte radio canada montréal